[Applaudissements]
on traverse la vie comment marche dans
la nuit sans savoir où l'on va on voit
passer les jours on a le souffle court
en luttant ce débat on dort en ce lundi
maintenant en vie des mots qu'on ne
on voit passer l'amour et on attend son
tour
une rose au bout des doigts on chante en
riant prix tendances
pour combler le silence ont cru ont
cherché une
les ans
pour faire taire nos souffrances cette
tournée donnera jardin
sans vraiment les pensées
jusqu'à
d'instinct
animer le brasier
[Musique]
on traverse la nuit comment marche la
pluie on évite les gens on a des bleus à
l'âme chacun ses petits drames qui cache
de grands tourments
on est ce qu'il veut les cours même
quand on est
conte à mes yeux brûlants
et quand une masse autant on ne change
pas de vols on garde encore ses gants
on chante on rit en priant dans
pour combler le silence
mon cher sur
m
nos souffrances
et aujourd'hui dedans
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce que
animer le brasier
[Musique]
ranimé le brasier
kan d'avoir trop pleuré
on souffle sur les cendres 10h quand un
simple baiser
[Musique]
avec ce tout
ok
puis en paix en
[Musique]
au comble
silence
auxerre c'est une
à présent
tour 10 de nos jetons
[Musique]
chez ce cas
fumer
animer le brasier ranimer le brasier
[Musique]
recevoir le gracier changeons qui
peut-être d'autres